so you've heard presumably about the
latest doomsday prophecy of
environmentalists they have found a new
villain to fight a new cancer to treat
and that is straws plastic straws
plastic straws are destroying mankind
and we have to get rid of them San
Francisco is the most recent city I
believe to ban straws they will now be
straw free they are ace they are a a
safe haven from the tyranny of straws so
you don't have to worry if you're in if
you're in San Francisco you don't have
to worry about walking down the street
and tripping over a straw and becoming
paralyzed which is you know that's
that's happened to at least three or
four people that I know it's very common
now you if you're in San Francisco you
still have to worry about walking on the
street and stepping on a used heroin
needle or slipping a puddle of human
feces but at least you don't have to
worry about straws other cities are also
banning straws Seattle's banned straws
Santa Barbara is coming down very hard
and what they're saying is that if you
are if you are caught being a straw
dealer you could get six months in jail
per straw all that you hand out so if
you're if you are a a waitress and at
Denny's and you make the mistake of
handing out a straw to one person you
get six months now if there's a say a
birthday party at Denny's which is a
great location for birthday party then
and you hand out straws to everybody you
go rogue and you just start handing out
straws left and right you can be looking
at twenty or thirty years in prison when
it when all is said and done I mean you
could if rather than handing out straws
if you had just if it was like a toddler
birthday party and you had just poured
shots of absinthe for all the toddlers
you would get less prison time than if
you were to hand out straws to them now
if you gave them straws to drink the
absinthe then I think you've really got
a problem that would actually be
execution I believe it's that's the rule
celebrities have gotten in on the act as
well they're they're recording PSAs
they're starting campaign
raising awareness about straws so now
everybody is aware of straws and it is
just it is turned in it into hysteria as
per usual we have a crisis because
everything has to be a crisis so we
can't just have a problem or we can't
just discuss an issue it has to be a
crisis it has to be oh my gosh we're all
gonna die that's what it has to be so
that's what it's become with straws now
you may have heard that these anti straw
measures are necessary because our straw
consumption habits are so out of control
we become straw addicts and the only way
to stop our straw obsession is to just
go cold turkey according to the figures
that you hear in the media Americans use
500 million straws a day per person not
only it's protective weight I think it's
it collectively ok so collectively
Americans use 500 million straws a day
that's more than 3 billion a week that
means if you connected all the straws
that we use in a year and you connected
them just and you line them all up they
would stretch 4 light years into space
and actually touch our neighboring star
and then be burned up and then you would
have this this this towering inferno of
straws that would fall down to the earth
and engulf us all and engulf the earth
in flames ok that's that's how many
straws we we use
if
the statistics that I just cited sound
made-up it's because they are
putting them connecting them into space
I made that up although who knows maybe
that would be true the 500 million bit
was made up by a nine-year-old child and
his made-up statistic is actually being
used by the media and by journalists and
by politicians who are passing laws
politicians passing laws are citing this
statistic that was invented by a fourth
grader a nine year old this is how he
did it okay nine-year-old child I think
back in 2011 was concerned about straws
which I mean it's great he's
environmentally conscious conscious and
I know this is not a criticism of the
nine-year-old Chuck but he is nine year
old nine years old so what he did was he
he got on the phone and he conducted an
informal phone survey with a few strong
manufacturing and based on his
conversation with them he guessed that
we probably use 500 millions trials a
day and now that guess by a
nine-year-old six years ago is being
cited as fact not even like a reportedly
we use 500 million straws a day or
allegedly we use strike or it's
estimated that maybe perhaps we use 500
million a day know if you read media
reports it's we use 500 million straws a
day is it true I mean do we actually use
500 million straws a day I have no idea
probably not seems a little high but
nobody's bothered to check it
everybody's just running with it I don't
know how to check that statistic but
just because you don't know how to check
it doesn't mean you could just use it if
you can't confirm it at all if it can't
be confirmed then that means you just
can't use it
but this is how it goes you see once a
stat even a made-up statistic with no
evidence to support it once it becomes
attached to a movement it is now carved
in stone and and you're not allowed to
question it once once the movement
adopts it you're not allowed to question
anymore so for another example think of
the statistic that claims that 20% of
all women in college are raped you've
heard you've heard that statistic before
20% are rape 20% I mean that is an
incredible statistic if it were actually
true you think about 20 so you're
telling me if I send my daughter to
college there's a 20% chance of this
happening why would anyone ever send
their daughter to college again in that
case I would any woman ever go to
college again if there's a 20% chance of
being raped I mean it's it's horrific
it's also invented that's an invented
statistic it is is ánot grounded in
reality there there is no factual basis
for it at all it is just invented but
feminists use it knowing that it's false
most of them at least the ones that are
leading the movement they know that this
statistic is total BS they use it anyway
because they figure that their aims are
noble and so it doesn't really matter if
they lie along the way so same for same
for environmentalists environmentalists
are notorious for doing us
environmentalists and feminists I would
say together those two movements are the
most inclined to just use fabricated
lies to advance their cause because they
think that their their aim is just so
noble and so good that that they it
gives them a pass an ethical kind of
hallway pass to use whatever measures
they they think are necessary here's the
problem though with using made-up
statistics first of all they're not true
so you're lying
if that doesn't bother you
but how about this you're hurting your
own case when you use made-up statistics
here's what happens you come in with
this crazy statistic
and first of all you've given people a
reason to discount not just that this
statistic but your entire case and then
if somebody corrects the stat and the
real number is lower than what you said
but still pretty bad the only thing
people will focus on is the fact that
you were wrong
so for instance if you go if you're very
concerned about drunk driving let's say
and it's it is something we should be
concerned about so you go and you say a
thousand people die every day from drunk
driving in America at first you're gonna
think that you're ridiculously inflated
and dishonest statistic is working
because a lot of people will hear that
and say oh my gosh
a thousand people real that I mean
that's really that's so high I we have
to do something a thousand people most
people when they hear a statistic if it
is if it is cited authoritative lis
especially in a news article they'll
just take it
at face value they won't question that's
how that's what that's how most people
react so it is at first you're gonna
find that using made-up statistics is a
very effective measure because most
people are just just don't think about
that they don't think about much at all
really and solve you tell them something
they'll go oh okay
well alright then that must be true
because somebody said it to me but
invariably some jerk who cares about
pesky little things like truth will come
along and say well no actually about
it's not a thousand people die a days
about it's about thirty a day who died
and then people everybody else the
unthinking masses who had 1,000 a day in
mind they're gonna hear that they're
gonna go oh well that's not so bad at
all in comparison I guess drunk driving
isn't the problem it's not a problem at
all I mean I yeah I thought we just went
from a thousand down to thirty well it's
like nothing so you had you had this
thing that that is certainly a problem
and now people won't see it as a problem
anymore because of the way that you
chose to approach it if you had just
been reasonable and honest and told the
truth maybe you could have made a
difference but instead you ruined your
whole campaign by basing it on nonsense
so environmentalists really need to get
this through their heads yes it is a
worthy goal to try to reduce our use of
plastic and yes straws are kind of
wasteful and and I don't think that we
use five hundred million a day but we
probably use a lot I mean maybe we use a
hundred million maybe we use two hundred
million I really don't think it's five
hundred million because that would
require every man woman child and infant
on average to use almost two straws a
day every day seven days a week 365 days
a year and I just and considering
they're now me I rarely ever use straws
I think I use a straw maybe once a month
I'm on like a once a month straw habit
and that's the case for pretty much
everyone in my family we don't have we
don't use there's not a lot of straw
usage going on in my family and I think
there are a lot of people like me who
just
don't use straws at all so it actually
would require considering they're people
who don't use straws at all that means
that there must be people out there
using like 10 or 15 straws a day and
considering the fact that hardly anyone
uses a straw unless they're eating out
like you're going to a fast-food
restaurant you're going to you're going
to a sit-down restaurant that's for most
people it's the only time straws ever
come up so that would require there to
be a lot of people who are eating out
like four or five times a day and
getting straws maybe there are some
people who do that I don't think it's
enough to get you up to 500 million so
whatever that whatever the statistic is
let's say it's a hundred million two
hundred million I don't know what it is
even if it's 50 million it's still a lot
it's still a lot so just drop the
hysterics drop the theatrics drop the
propaganda drop the lies stop trying to
force the issue through laws and
regulations and just instead make your
point and encourage people to moderate
themselves a little bit that's all you
could just say look you know it's theirs
look at there's 300 plus million people
in America we do eat out we tend to eat
out a lot get a lot of fast food so that
means that there's a lot of straws being
used it's maybe not 500 million a day
but it's still a lot it's kind of a
wasteful thing so maybe we should let's
just moderate and maybe if you go to UM
if you go to to McDonald's and you get a
soda unless you really need the straw
maybe tell them you know I don't need to
struggle like you could just encourage
people to take measures like that and
it's fine and and so people are
moderating a little bit it's not
hysteria it's just kind of a reasonable
thing but when everything has to be a
crisis when everything is leading to the
annihilation of life on Earth and when
you start using these overly emotional
appeals and saying somebody said to me
on Twitter yesterday they said they said
they said well art aren't you concerned
about your straw ending up law lodged in
the nose of a sea turtle aren't you
concerned about that and I had to say no
not really I mean I have to be honest
that is that does not make my when I'm
gonna list the top 100 things in life
I'm worried about I don't think the
nasal passages of sea turtles really
makes the list at all and also I think
the chances of the straw that I'm you
know using to drink my soda with the
chances of that ending up in the nose of
a sea turtle the chances are vanishingly
small even if I were to take the straw
and go to the ocean myself and chuck it
into the ocean and say take that sea
turtles even if I did that there's
almost no chance that that particular
straw ends up lodged in the nose of a
sea turtle so drop all that stuff and
just be honest of course if you were
honest you'd have to admit that plastic
straws
while it while there maybe it's a worthy
thing to try to you know just through
our own efforts to moderate a little bit
still what it comes down to a plastic
straws really aren't that big of a deal
in the grand scheme here here are some
facts for you okay
here's some actual statistics if we're
going to talk about plastic waste ending
up in the ocean which this straw
conversation all seems to be centered
around that this idea that all the the
fight that's supposed to 500 million
straws today that we use it's all ending
up in the ocean and it's creating this
huge raft of straws that is just
floating through the Pacific and will
eventually crash into Asia and then
maybe move the continent of Asia shifted
over which will shift that and then all
the continents will come together again
and which actually maybe wouldn't be
such a bad thing maybe we could have you
well it will finally be all one world
isn't that what the Liberals want so
rather than painting scenarios like that
if you were to actually face the facts
and be honest about it you would have to
admit that 95 percent 95 percent of the
plastic in the ocean comes from ten
rivers in Asia and Africa
so we could stop using plastic
altogether it would it would make little
difference 60% of all the plastic waste
in the ocean comes from China Thailand
Vietnam Indonesia and the Philippines so
so again plastic from the United States
is hardly a problem at all comparatively
in terms of percentages
it's it's it's hardly a problem
think about it 95% 95% of the plastic in
the ocean comes from Asia in Africa
that leaves 5% of plastic to be split
between the entire continent of Europe
North America South America and
Australia that means we all have 5% of
plastic to split and and so if you're to
divvy it down how much of that belongs
to the United States I don't know but
it's what it's significantly less than
5% and then of our small percent let's
say it's even I don't know 1% although
it's probably less than that let's say
it's 1% how much of that small
percentage is below is is is due to
straws
so it's just such a tiny tiny percent
that the United States in fact the
entire Western world could stop using
plastic all together and it would make
almost no difference to the ocean
because at least 95% of the plastic
would still be there
um
that's the reality does that mean that
we should make no effort at all it's a
kerb our plastic consumption no I'm not
saying that sure we should make you know
yeah it's it like I said it's a worthy
goal I guess it's it's even if we're not
worried about it
ending up in the ocean it's just a
matter of general wastefulness
you know there's no reason to use things
you don't need and
there's no reason a lot of times if
you're at a fast-food restaurant maybe
they'll give you a straw you don't even
use it so it just adds like six equation
so yeah we could we could moderate a bit
and and that's it and that's all you
have to say forget the laws forget the
campaign's the PSA forget the lies and
the made-up statistics in this area just
be just be honest a little bit tell
people the truth and then we can respond
reasonably and everything will be fine
and we'll and we'll just live our lives
that's all that's my that's my proposal
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed